a diorama is an art form that is all
about thinking inside the box an artist
builds a 3d scene with an epoxy
structure it has one side open for
viewing the scene can be true to life or
inspired by a place or event and
sometimes a diorama can change the way
we look at the world the assistant
selects leaves that have been pressed
for about a week and can still be
handled without breaking she punches out
many leaf shapes with a handy crafting
tool and accumulates piles in various
colors because it's punched from actual
leaves the miniature foliage looks very
authentic next she works a lump of
polymer clay until it's soft and narrow
she inserts the clay into an extruder
and presses it through perforations at
the end
[Music]
this creates strands of clay that looked
like tiny lo mein noodles
[Music]
she arranges the clay on a tiny paper
plate
she then brushes brown paint onto the
noodles to imitate sauce the clay mini
meals are now complete and the artist
uses them to create a fake menu sign she
snaps pictures of each of the Chinese
food selections now she builds the
diorama walls using foam sheets she
glues mirrored plastic panels to one
wall the reflections will make this
diorama seem more spacious the artist
and her assistant attached the walls of
the diorama to a tile pattern foam floor
they taped the walls together from the
back
[Music]
the scattered grass and dirt throughout
the scene an overturned trash can and
yellowed newspapers on the floor imply
the sudden departure of humans they
decide the scene needs more grass and
dirt so that its tribute more across the
floor
they now place the motorbike into the
scene empty takeout containers in a
plastic box in the open doorway add to
the illusion of an urban landscape
returning to nature they add the third
wall and the ceiling with its
fluorescent lighting the scene has been
set and now the artist focuses an
eight-by-ten film camera on it
this large format camera will produce a
high-resolution image she adjusts the
lighting and when satisfied takes three
shots
this is a carefully crafted scene viewed
through the cameras I